you are a Sasquatch guy I'm a crypted
guy or a cryptoid guy whatever you want
to call it the Cryptids and cryptoid I
don't think the Sasquatch is technically
oh no technically a crypted you know
what I'm talking about though I don't
know what a crypted is so a crypted is
like a skinwalker or a moth man or the
chupacabra or Legend mythical right but
they're called cryptons so for me I'm a
big crypto guy you know why cuz why the
[__] not but why wouldn't he be crypted
I don't know I think he's considered
something different let me check but
like I think this is the problem I have
Bigfoot supposedly captured on the side
of a mountain in Colorado right yeah
from a train it's already fishy to me
why Nam Bron sent us the following video
while we were on a Bigfoot Expedition
here is the latest reported Bigfoot
captured on video bro that Silverton
Colorado this appears to be captured
from the train that runs between here's
the problem I have with it look at that
that is a dude no is not in a [__]
suit original that is a but here's my
thing like why not just be open to the
open to the possibility that that is the
missing link between ape and man like
why not because that's what Bigfoot is
Bigfoot is the missing link between apes
and humans that's literally it why not
be open to the possibility that this is
what we're looking at that's my thing
it's like why not not a Debbie Downer
but why always put it into the dirt why
not just have have fun looking at it and
going yo that look at the possibility
100% Walks Like a person it's a missing
link between human and apes that would
make sense 100% walk like a person
that's Evolution and why let me ask you
this like why is he out in the open and
not in cover why is this what what's
with the sitting down he's trying to
camouflage dude so how he's trying to
have people not see how would he know
that if he if he's so smart right this
is a this is a myth iCal creature that's
been so good at evading humans doesn't
hear a [__]
train doesn't hear a train and I think
he does but how does but how do but he's
got he's got to assume that not all
trains have people on it oh is that
right I bet you okay and then if this
maybe not I don't know AIT of the doubt
this mythical creature knows that he's
being filmed so he sits down oh that is
a [__] human or maybe he does it
every time he sees a train in case sees
this possibility of him being seen then
why would he come out train time in mid
daylight oh you think he has a [__]
schedule of when all the trains come
through we're talking about you listen
dude you think he's got a pen and paper
out there right why would he hiding why
would he be hiding if he's not cognizant
of the trains why is he hiding from the
train he's cognizant of the train but
he's not C he can't tell time like he's
he can't tell how do you know you can't
he can't tell me that it's 1:40 p.m. but
he can hear a [__] train coming yeah
maybe he was already in the walk before
the train showed up then so he just
[__] just squatted right when this
dude has his camera I'm not going to lie
before he had when he squatted like
before that obviously you can see where
he squats but if I played you that video
from right where he squatted would you
be able to tell me where he was what's
that yeah dude of course not that you've
seen the video of course but like it was
he tried to camouflage he looked like
the right color for the side of that
Hill that's an animal Instinct do a try
and camouflage you know what else is the
Instinct of a human is to know that
these people are on a train looking for
Sasquatch I'm going to put my [__]
Sasquatch suit on because that's what
that was and I'm gonna walk in front of
the train here's what I'm telling you
right now if this thing exists which it
doesn't you [__] wackos if this thing
exists and it has evaded for so long
this is not how it's getting caught out
in the wide open with no cover this is a
person who knows that the train is
coming by and I would go so far that
looked like a pretty large person though
aren't there large people
that like a large person if we went back
to the video dude it is so clearly
assumed there's zero muscle in the chest
like like a uh like a like an animal
would have zero muscle in the chest
long spindly arms zero muscle dude just
a tall human in a suit that's it no
Muscle really on the legs look at this
thing dude what okay that does not
you're telling me that's a [__] wild
animal that with no muscle tone on the
legs loose on the legs loose no muscle
loose get out of here dude no that not
an animal like that look dude a bear
a deer a any wild animal is muscle has
muscle definition there's no muscle it's
a
Loose H he looks like he's wearing a
tiki hut this is not a mythical giant
muscular creature it looks like a hairy
dude who used to follow the Almond
Brothers that's what he looks like is
there any way you can slow like how fast
it plays or is that not an option on
YouTube listen man I'm just telling you
play speed nice right now yeah well you
do five yeah 025 is fine I'm telling you
right now look at the lack of
muscle dude's kind of got a fat ass
though I'm not gonna lie lack of no
muscle in the arms and the big one is no
muscle in the legs no muscle in the
booty look at those things dude a
[__] Bigfoot if that's what it is
well you're telling me it's a cross
between an ape and man right it's the
missing link between ape and man Missing
Link which walks around all day makes
lives in the eats whatever the [__]
look at all the wild animals that have
they have muscle dude fair enough this
is a human in a suit fair enough at
least get me a superhero suit you know
what I'm saying no I'm still believe in
it's it's I will say though it's a
pretty good video it's a Prett it's a
pretty good video fun it's fun it is fun